when I was younger I was very easily so
I thought like you just heard managers
[Music]
welcome back Girls welcome back
um we've got a guests in the building
today I'm going to ask you we're angled
yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna ask this guest
not to speak until I allow us to speak
okay allow them to speak speak until
spoken yeah yeah [__] keep quiet yeah
it'd be a good girl and keep quiet
um so guys right so we have a very very
special guest in the building today
um and what I want to say about this
person is that this person finally
enough
actually and actually mean this
genuinely yeah I'm not gonna say this
for other guests yeah because this one I
mean genuinely okay in the podcast in
space yeah
I don't know should take this wrong way
or not her
Fame and her like size of show and stuff
like that is not uh reflective of her
talent in agreed agreed yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah this person
deserves to have like at least a million
Subs on YouTube at the minute and I
can't work it yeah I clocked her Tick
Tock like last year early summer time
okay probably
uh yeah like May June last year okay and
I remember thinking this girl's actually
good yeah and I'm a crew I critique
podcast I critique and I was like okay
sound this girl's actually decent
um I think she's actually gonna do well
and I remember
um
seeing Spotify did a post on Instagram
they did a poll or whatever I was like
what's the best UK podcast yeah and the
only reason I saw it is because someone
obviously tagged Us in it okay I was
like oh I want to see what people are
saying yeah and then I I'm not gonna
bait out yet but it was just CNT CNT CNT
CNT and I was like and you have the like
the obvious ones yeah yeah Cynthia and I
was like what even is that yeah yeah and
I clicked on it and I was like raw that
makes sense it's the same one yeah yeah
yeah yeah this [__] again bro and I was
like right okay she's doing stuff yeah
um and then I remember
uh Spotify invited us to like a little
Fort Park day out oh yeah yeah this girl
was drunk off it oh from the jump shot
early yeah
she was drunk
um I think we were in the same teeth the
same top as well the same brand yeah we
were wearing the same brand yeah yeah
yeah she had a little boxing yeah
um but anyway
that was the first day we actually met
her in person and ever since that day
um she has been nothing but like very
very very lovely to us support
supportive yeah
um and just like what I said friendly
yeah yeah and just like what I mentioned
for taser when taser was on the show
yeah he's like one of the very few
people that I would consider an actual
friend right in this space not just an
industry friend someone who actually
looks out for us and cares about us yeah
um and doesn't just chat to us because
we're in the same space at the same time
facts um so without any further ado
that is how you say it yeah that is how
you say it yeah it sounded weak on my
mouth because you've never said it I've
never said that any further Ado please
welcome Madam Joyce guys
how you feeling how are you feeling God
what
I love you guys
oh my God
thank you very much it was jokes hi guys
Hi how are you I'm amazing I'm happy to
be here not gonna lie I am sincerely
sincerely very gassed to be here and I
don't know why I'm just so excited to be
here yes I can't baby
[Applause]
so right what we do when we have guests
on as it's very rare we like to break
that it's not that we really need to
break the ice so we've actually won
pretty easy on you but we like to break
the ice with guests and we have a little
roast so we asked the internet to roast
Madame Joyce yeah um food that's going
to run a couple bars and and see see
what they have to say okay I'm ready
you're ready I'm ready me I rest back
yes
we've just got a couple in it he's gonna
read some as well okay yeah all right
she looks like an exotic cricket
that one what does that even mean I
don't know
it doesn't make sense because it's quite
slim
for context I used a picture let me show
you I use the picture
um you're wearing a dress yes um Awards
was it the Bristol Awards yes um just
for context let me pull it up well he
said that exotic though
sorry yeah I'm trying to find this one
it was this picture but this it was this
exact picture oh okay yeah I see I see I
see I see it with the wings I see it
yeah
all right gang that's a cute picture
all right what's the next one uh the
next one is
she looks like the sort of person to eat
spaghetti and have it hanging out of her
mouth
I am that person eating spaghetti is a
very embarrassing it's very tasking
because if you don't spin it properly
then it does dangle a bit and it's just
not part of the estate I do like a young
tongue wrap around the thing yeah yeah
so if so I spin it but yeah like the
it's not always enveloped around the
fork so the bits that's done were like
let's say this before I'm like you
couldn't I promise you I'd done you yeah
it has said my tongue game is strong
okay yeah
that's yuck bro I I do it because of my
beard I get food in my bed okay
all the time yeah yeah all right
um she looks like she pronounces the K
and no
that's what I wanted was dread
and you pronounce as well
just for days I dude
I don't know her but she looks evil
oh no what villainous things you know
what I do have a bit of a village style
but I would like to become a gently nice
person you think you're arresting [__]
face that's the problem I have a very
resting [__] face yeah and I feel like
until people speak to me I'm just in my
zone like I'm the type of person where
if people see me on road double black
dress are you all right are you all
right and I'm like yes I'm good I'm just
living in the moment it's like okay
people want me to go around and be like
now you're cool to be fair that same
thought Park day yeah I was thinking um
you mentioned that and we did I'm one of
those people I'm not I don't speak
unless I'm smoking too yeah same here to
be fair we can be in the same vicinity
for the whole day and I will not talk to
you yeah but that's only because you did
not talk to me I call it Petty Call It
Whatever yeah yeah yeah yeah but the
minute you talk to me oh my God I'm
outside hey French besties yeah that's
literally me I don't know I don't talk
to anyone no I don't talk to anyone
either fair enough all right I've got a
couple more rows here these rice are not
banging is this what they call babies
had to offer swears do you wanna Joyce
I'm not going to lie to you we had to I
had a private team yeah I said message
Jimmy a couple days before and say
listen I don't know how Joyce is going
to handle some of these so dumb them
down spaghetti is that all you have to
offer give me the real stuff man [__] it
out are you sure yeah
that's actually calm
all right I'm like okay I'm sure
everybody's listening to 15 I'm sure you
guys could see better all right guys
she looks like a mix between Chris Rock
and Wendy Williams
[Laughter]
that one spun me bro
Wendy Williams is murdered
I have no offense bro Wendy Williams is
smart
honestly like
she really inspires me so funny enough
for someone to say that I look like as
hilarious that's that's hilarious I mean
I hope it's Wendy Williams before not
what do you think it's 2023. it could be
if it's 20 25
you're a [__] I've got one from from
here all right here
from memory from memory can I just say
something they dumped it down because
they thought I couldn't handle it but
they stored it in their hearts to laugh
that it was like
um it was a that's a raven moment where
I saw it and then the whole camera just
pan into my eyes and it burned in my
brain I was like raw scrap that one what
was it this is this one said
[Music]
we had to dump the whole thing down for
you Joyce I'm just gonna lie I'm not
gonna lie to you baby you know what I'm
still not that's not that bad to be fair
that's not that bad no that's not that
bad because so if I start whispering in
your ear with these big ass lips what
you gonna do oh no obviously the tip is
gonna it's gonna yeah
[Laughter]
[Applause]
I'm sweating bro the same all right I've
got a couple more give it to me
um because of those lashes I can't tell
if she's squinting hard or trying to
fart quietly
do you know what cult babies I mean if
listen I know you haven't had that many
guesses but if you're gonna roast
someone they really want the roast give
it to me yeah damn I saw someone say
she's built like a deep breath
[Laughter]
foreign
[Music]
so oh I'm sweating Jesus Christ
what we want to do now yeah and this is
actually I'm gassed about this because
as much as I feel like we know you
I know bits and Bobs about your like
actual life and we want to know like
this is the segment we want to do like
called origin story yeah yeah so like
like let's just paint a picture of what
like
school choice or growing up Joyce how
you turned into Madame Joyce okay okay
so this is your turn this is your time
so like for example right so I knew
[Applause]
this is the research wow wow see the wig
God God what year is that this is year
seven so I must have been like 13 here
can I tell you a story yeah I'm not I
don't think I mentioned this on my I did
so basically this particular wig that
I'm wearing yeah I had to wear it
because it was back in the day where
Rihanna had the side car yeah yeah now
what's my name yeah she had the side car
and all the girls were going crazy and
we were shaving the size of her hair and
shaving the backs now I decided to take
my mom's Clippers yeah and shave it but
you know obviously Mandan that do it you
have to have different levels in it yeah
and I didn't know that so obviously with
the raw thing I used the raw
skin I use the routine one all over yeah
I just literally shaved the side so and
then there was patches so what I will do
is I will use mascara to cover the Pat
the board so anyways I will go to school
like that and one day I went to school
like that my mom came home and she saw
me but usually when my mom is annoyed
she's not on the ride what are you doing
but she was really like calm so I said
listen Rihanna she must slide this [__]
like this is a style so she was like oh
Joyce let me come and help you
um do I stand right so my full name is
just just sort it out you know my mom
took the Clipper and I said okay Mom I
sat down my mom went like this oh Lord
she literally shaved the whole thing oh
so
it was too late because I couldn't you
can't carry Rihanna but yeah
I think so I was bold
now this is the wig that my mommy bought
for me
but the fact that I was bold but it's a
synthetic wig and I swear to God I had
that once a day a week for like seven
months so that's why it's standing on my
shoulder you see how there's no moving
it's not moving it's just like standing
on myself standing on my head yeah yeah
I'm funny enough just I would just as I
was leaving disco because I was really
servently bullied so I was bullied at
school I had our year seven so my acne
Flair came up really early so I was like
30 years old with like
his name is Wesley and he's in jail so
[__] you yeah yeah yeah [__] you in it
he's in jail saying you can't really hit
it
he was like tell me you have more spots
than I have friends
oh if you [__] laugh
oh
I'm laughing I'm not actually not
laughing this is not talking to you bro
I had to hold my breath you have more
spots than friends yeah he's at the
handball spots though friends yeah come
on you're seven yeah
off the door
so he used to proper believe me he's a
gel now so [__] him but yeah anyways on
the last day of school year I was
basically moving I was moving schools in
it because I moved to Bedford this is in
Luton okay and um the boys had basically
you went to school in Luton yeah I went
to school I've been around
which one I went to uh not that one I
went to stop sleep okay I was an eggnode
yeah right my ex went to ignored is she
about me
[Music]
oh yeah she's a couple years older than
you damn she would actually know to be
fair she would have been in year 11
years in year seven okay so I didn't
know the year like she I don't know she
may be
past me yeah she might have been dashing
robbers at you and all sorts yeah
as well so yeah double yeah
anyways the last day of school the boys
everyone found out I had a wig on
because my friends told everybody that I
had a wig that's right I know villainous
[__] yes so on the last day of school
demand them were planning to pull off my
wig in front of everyone I know it's so
bad but thank God luckily my mom picked
me up at lunchtime so after lunch my mom
decided to come and get me to move so my
dignity wasn't taxed before I left but
yeah it was the bullying was bad and I
feel like
um my personality stem from the fact of
I guess wanting to make friends yeah
yeah so it was one of those things where
because I'd moved around a lot maybe
like 12 13 different schools she had to
really try and be I was always the new
girl so I had to be trying to make
friends and be friendly and put myself
out there so I think it was just
something that I kind of learned in a
way to just not be to go in the
playground by herself because everyone
already formed groups so yeah first of
all this week is the hot ass mess
but yeah I feel like that's where kind
of like my kind of I guess talking to
people and finding it easy to talk to
people came from because I have been put
in so many different environments
whereby I had to meet different people
and I had to be adaptable okay so I
guess like when people now are like oh
my God Joy is that you know when I meet
you I feel like I'm known you for a long
time it's just something that I guess
I've picked up from constantly being
around different environments yeah and
being thrown into the deep end
constantly going on sorry if you're born
in Ireland right yes and but you went to
school in Bedford Luton and where else
did you go to London so I was in London
for a bit okay I grew up in I was born
in Ireland yeah then I went to London
and I went to Luton then I went back to
London then I'll move to Bedford yeah
but now you're back in London obviously
yeah now I'm back in London now I'm back
in London but this is moving around with
my mummy and stuff yeah damn bro yeah so
um
what age we're hop skipping jumping bro
what age are we talking like first time
picking up a camera
oh
God you know I'm a bit of a late bloomer
I don't uh actually no let's Trace back
let's roll back
jobs
okay all right let's talk jobs so
[Music]
first ever job was in River Island as a
Christmas temp okay so I had land on my
CV obviously 17 no experience needed
money did whatever it took so I must
have ladder my CV and said I had worked
in a couple of places or whatever so
River Island took me on as a Christmas
Temp and they said I did so well that
they ended up taking me on full time oh
mad how old are you no not four times
sorry part time so I was like 17 18 here
so that was my first ever job obviously
we did The Cheeky paper round and that
you know but can I just say paper rounds
is actually [__] teeth because how
are you walking around for four three
hours and they're paying you 20 pounds
yeah my little brother had a paper on
them my mom was like are you seeing what
a good child looks like are you seeing
what like are you seeing what like
entrepreneurship looks like what so
comparing YouTuber yeah and he was
folding papers and I was like Mom like
this is
yeah
is it younger or older younger he's
younger you see you see what you see
have that younger sister yeah that your
parents always compare you to that you
grow up surprised that you don't hate
each other yeah me and my younger sister
I like that because it's like every time
I do something July will never do that
and every time diola did something bad
it would be me oh yeah recently my
little sister got caught vaping mad
so this is what you and Jason are doing
together Joy oh no
matter something bad like yeah you're
involved yeah you're an influence I'm
the influencer straight off the madness
that's what I'm doing together
[Laughter]
I'll send for my mama
girl anyways
um I forgot the question uh jobs River
Island yeah
and then oh God so I was a care
assistant can I just say pick up all the
[__] care assistance yeah
someone's spot in his mouth yeah it's
like yoga straight in his mouth
someone's bite
in his mouth
oh bad I forgot hell yeah man was drapes
the next man can I just probiotics
let me tell you the first ever time I
did care so after after okay he's a cat
yeah I'm the kid that's a hot Escape
so I did River Islands yeah then I did
Tesco okay I hate to Tesco
so much so on my last day I literally
trashed the counter oh wow so I was
working at the deli counter where they
do the [__] pizzas and the fish so
you had fish here yeah Delhi ham cheese
um sausage roll and then you have the
pizza on the side yeah
I decided I haven't I've had enough yeah
I was filled you know you know if you
guys do retail you have these old women
that have been there since 1997.
but you come in and they want you to
have that 26 years of experience it's
like Margaret be calm yeah Margaret calm
down yeah and I had a lot of older women
in my daddy counter and they were so
nasty to me so one day I decided to
before I left I trashed the counter I
was throwing ham throwing sausage roll I
took the the pizza I put all the the
tickets you know the one that said
sausage and I put it in the barbecue
sauce I was playing I said if I'm gonna
go I'm gonna go with a bank and I did
that and I flunked everything and then I
put I I put my resignation on the
receipt I said I'm going [__] you bye
and they accepted it you got bollocks so
then after that I did care now can I
just get paid for your last shift do you
remember who knows
who [__] does who knows but my
job after that was I was a carer system
yeah yeah guys being a care assistant
is so big up for the care assistance
because mentally it's [__] like I was
dealing with people within dementia and
I remember my first ever shift chair
I was in the dementia unit it's easy
it's an easy job to get I actually
applied to be in the kitchen because
that was the job I did before at Tesco
and the guy was like
why don't you just do care like it's so
easy just come to the care side [__] the
kitchen and I said okay cool yeah the
first day walk through the double doors
there's this old man he's got his head
down he's like just walk in
confused
walking so I'm like okay cool oh Old man
cute
I looked down I didn't realize he had
his pads in his hand so he had like his
his [__] pants
and he's just doing and I'm like okay
cute old man with a pad in his hand okay
but the guy was like literally like
Zombie thing yeah doing this thing I kid
you not the guy stop the guy's like old
man started sprinting and literally
catapulted the pad and threw it at me
nah did it hit you
you will see poo on your hand nice
you listen I promise I'll burn my skin
off I'm not doing any of that
I've seen Pooh in every shade and every
color
yellow poo pink poo gray poo
consistency
there's people that will spit at you
like especially to mention that will
spit at you especially dementia like did
I mentioned that was pretty even
sometimes you're black how old are you
they'll say oh I'm 29 girl you know
you're not oh wow I'm 29 years old like
girl you old oh my God no you not Jesus
Christ
you have to play along I'm not playing
alone yeah yeah well that's long that's
long where's my mommy girl use 80
where'd you live oh that's my mommy
Joyce I promise that will scare me
where's my mommy I couldn't be left
alone
the red tag girl where do you think he
was mighty she's buried boys like
seriously
that oh the bump is dead yeah how old
are you I'm 25. okay girls yes listen if
that's who you want to be who am I to
tell you who you should have been born
on a leap year in there she could be 25.
go shut up
but I think one thing again I always
take things I always take
every part of my life as a lesson and I
don't feel like that was a waste of time
because one again it taught me to be
adaptable because one thing I loved
about that job was the stories like old
people got some stories the ones that
are not dementia
they have some stories
yeah yeah
like there's stories of some of them
have been married for over like 40 years
and they used to tell me about you know
like working in the newspaper and how
newspapers used to be printed and stuff
and people that were in Wars like they
used to fight they were fighting with
the kind of Hitler like the man where
they are like and I always find it quite
fascinating I feel like again that just
kind of
helps me in times of communication like
talking to all people talking to young
people and also just being hard working
because when you're working in care 12
hour shift on your feet sometimes you
sometimes you have to hoist some big
people nah like honestly like when I
left care I was henched because when
you're sorry some of your grandmothers
or granddaughters they're big and you
have to be rolling them how long did you
do that how long would you do that I did
that for about two years 18 19 years
that's a long time two years yeah
because it was an easy job like honestly
I was like I I didn't know what I wanted
to do and you know like when you go
through like a job application yeah you
have to do so much screaming round one
sometimes if Ken they don't even ask for
your CV they say can you walk yes okay
come on okay
yeah
it's a waste time as long as you have
your DBS you are good so I didn't want
to go through the process of this job
and also I didn't know what I wanted to
do I had a I had a um
crisis for majority of my life yeah okay
what do I want my life to be because I
did the first I spent College doing
acting acting didn't work out and then I
spent the rest of like four or five
years confused
you told me one time you did customer
service as well no yeah in Northampton
you know what I said to go listen let me
tell you something guys any of the cult
babies if you work at Northampton
Borough Council yeah I think my mom
works on the fancy program if anybody
wants one or fancy Borough Council and
they know a woman yeah in court care
called Stephanie tell her I said she
should suck her [__] mom tell her to
suck I swear tell her to suck
suck your mom Stephanie
Stephanie was actually one of my worst
she's like literally you know those
people yeah and you know what Society
needs them where they are so invested in
the job yeah jobs worthy yeah yeah but
she just used to do too much so
just before I started my show I was
working in Northampton Borough Council
um and I had this manager called
Stephanie and my God she just used to do
too much you know what this woman said
to me she said that I stand the tea
obviously I used to like pick up the
phones and and speak to people and stuff
and she was like you know what try not
to be so like ghetto uh I said that she
said that to the point she said that
obviously because us black people were
so conditioned to no snitch and no
snitch and no snitching I never called
HR and sibilis I wish I [__] did yeah
I wish I could HR but yeah I did that
job and I absolutely hated it yeah again
I was traveling from Luton to
Northampton it took me an hour and a
half every day to get to work wow
um and it was and it was during covert
times
so it was just it was exhausted and I
think
this is when I was just like God I'm
tired yeah I'm tired of going through
these jobs that I absolutely hate I'm
tired of living a life with no purpose I
think my frustration was that I had so
much energy yeah and I had so much like
to give to give even it was being
directed into the wrong things or wasn't
being directed into something I enjoyed
and I think that that was the
frustration at that time and um I
remember during that job during that
time I got had got fired I said somebody
said God I want to work by myself I
wanna I want to work by my I want to
work for myself like I don't want to do
this and I got fired and I remember
crying and I remember just like God just
speaks to me and saying you know what
yeah okay now you work for yourself and
I'm like no I just got fired he said no
now you work for yourself so what are
you going to do with the time and I
think um during during that time a
couple months later is when I started
the show okay
um that's mad based on what yeah okay
honestly No One's Gonna believe me but
I've all like God gave me the show
so this is the this is the honest truth
I sat down one day and I was I
remembered the time I was in my bedroom
guys I kid you not I owned my landlord
like 2K yeah at this time I just I just
been fired I remember 2K I'm freaking
where the [__] am I gonna get money from
like I'm so poor right now like poverty
has caught me yeah I want Universal
Credit I don't know what the [__] I'm
gonna do yeah because it's covered the
level could have come to my house so she
was just on the phone I said okay [__]
what you gonna do I still hear [__]
yeah
sitting down in my room and for some
reason I was just so reassured that
everything was going to be okay okay and
I remember I haven't told the story you
know funny enough
um and I remember one time I was sitting
down and I was and I just heard start a
podcast
and I was like podcasts
and now I didn't make I had never
watched a podcast prior to this didn't
know about podcasts I was like but I
knew there was around but I wasn't like
an avid podcast Watcher yeah what was
this 2020 yeah
20 20 21 because it's not long ago I'm
locked in I'm locked in and I was like
okay
funny enough actually let me retract two
years later right two years prior sorry
I actually wanted to start a podcast
when I was in uni because I came to I
went to UNI for one year but for the one
year I remember I was making voice notes
um and I was like okay I want to do I
wanna I would just I just to get used to
myself talking because I thought oh okay
okay I was always very uncomfortable on
camera and stuff I never liked taking
pictures of myself I was just very
awkward when the camera came on okay so
I'd sit in my room in uni and I'd make
voice notes of myself talking about
things dating and stuff and just just so
you see how you would sound and stuff
that was like two years prior so again
fast forward to to the house that I owe
money to you
yeah yeah all I had was start a podcast
and I said okay of course I started
watching podcasts and I I came across
like 90s baby and three shots and all
those people and I was like these people
are really cool I love this and the show
was really
something to put my energy into okay I
never thought that it was gonna be big
but
I just thought I I'm a creative at heart
I love to create things so I think my
energy was spent building the show
building the name thinking of the name
thinking of the color scheme concept
where am I going to have it like you
know the whole the whole process I was
more excited about the process of
actually starting
um
so yeah within the first time I heard it
started podcast
I spent about two weeks researching two
weeks putting everything together yeah
and then I just posted my first episode
and I remember my first episode I guess
Mac wasn't on oh my God we've been there
in here yeah we've had issues episode
your guest mic is not on but somebody
that comes that causes through chaos
that's like I'm always like chaotic
because my life generally is that
chaotic and I'm very used to stuff like
that so I was like girl just [__] put
out I wrote I use my I used my Universal
Credit to pay for the studio time I was
like you know okay cool I was like [__]
it okay wait how much you get there for
Universe credit
2015 at the time when it was covered
they bumped it off of it so yeah they
had a bit of change and I think my my
thing was 150 pounds my studio time was
150 pounds of 250 for the month 850 for
the studio time yeah
and that was it I was I was insane
I wanted to stop something and I started
there and yeah that's that's where we
are do you remember my first guess was a
very amazing gentleman called holiday
Diva and he was already in the space
okay so
um he was he was at his upcoming he's a
content creator absolutely amazing but
he's also my friend and I just kind of I
I originally wanted to start it with
somebody okay
but I didn't have any friends okay yeah
one I didn't have any friends and two I
didn't have anyone that I knew I could
rely on you were in London every week
now is it still in Lieutenant okay so I
was dragging my I was dragging myself
from Luton I would jump the trade to
London every week backwards and forth
the studio spot was in London it was in
London
I didn't have anyone that I could rely
on to be like I don't want to do this
so I was like I'm gonna give people the
option so even if for example I would
spend four weeks with some busy at least
they would have the choice on the fifth
to be like Joyce I can't do this and
then I'd have someone come in that was
the actual plan because you know it's
difficult as you guys probably have
experience working with people to get
people in week by week to be as
dedicated as you especially when you're
first starting yeah now that the show's
established for people to come on is
that yeah just I'll do it but that's
because the show's been built yeah when
you're starting something to for people
to put money in and time in to not know
where it's going it's always hard but I
think I kind of saw the vision and I
would I just believed in it yeah let's
go ah so where did the where did The
Madam come into play so
we're going back to back to the wig babe
Instagram and stuff Twitter was a proper
Community yeah guys if you know you're
knowing it like you probably don't know
because you weren't calling it but I've
always been cool
back in the day Twitter was a comedian
everybody's having names
so there was a girl called Paulina and I
have to give it to her she was Gandhi
and I was 16 she was 19. and um when I
was 16 people used to tell me I used to
act a lot older than I was so every time
Pauline needs to see me she should be
like my damn job
so it just it just stuck so one day I
was looking for a Twitter name and I was
like sure doesn't sound too bad and I
just put Madame Joyce and it just kind
of stuck so I think when I came into the
space I might change it though but when
I came into the space it was like yeah
Madame Joyce was right
so when did you so obviously like you
started the show
um your your bus in Universal Credit
when did you because now you do like
show aside now you do all sorts so how
did you start like diversifying into
other [__]
so I started my show I've always been
inspired by
the personalities of the space
um I grew up with like Peak Mill Nella
Rose Patricia Brad who were YouTubers
Grace agilore YouTubers and I kind of
love just how they were on camera and
just kind of like performed and just
brought something brought something out
of me as a viewer and I think my show
helped me be a better personality
because like I said I was very
uncomfortable on camera yeah but I feel
like
I always say confidence is like an
elastic band I was always very confident
outside of being on camera but I felt
like as soon as the camera comes on I
had to be some I had to pretend to be
someone and I felt like I was when I
started I thought I was a bit too Hood
for YouTube I said I never wanted to do
YouTube because I thought I was a bit
too fabulous and we were in a space
where we had people like women Bellow
adiola Patron Mario Musa who are very
like
nor did I have the skill to pretend yeah
but I felt like when
I went on my show and I just allowed
myself to be brass yeah it was like a
safe space to me and then being on
camera allowed me to be myself so I
think the first thing that I ever did
was a word on the cab
okay yeah yeah yeah did you really I
need to dig it up yeah all right no
that's a girl because I look a lot
skinnier there and obviously because I
was hungry
okay
dating show because I knew I was like I
want to be I want to be a personality I
want to be a performer yeah I don't just
want to be a podcast star
um because yeah I don't want to be a
podcast I did the word on the cab thing
and that blew up that was like that did
numbers that did good thing so when
people started seeing that and then and
the thing is I was
putting myself out that people weren't
coming to me I emailed word on the cab
first
we got maybe like 20K or 30k tick
tockers at the time and I was holding I
said yes hello my name is Joyce I've got
30k on Tick Tock and I'm you know and I
was putting myself forward this and then
I did BuzzFeed and I reached out to them
so I'm one of those people yeah I was so
hungry so I was literally going for a
LinkedIn like I was going through
Linkedin yeah and sending emails finding
like who's the production manager of
this or who's the agent for that and I
was emailing it boy I'm trying for stuff
like that yeah
even the BuzzFeed thing
um I knew I wanted to work with BuzzFeed
because I saw them doing content and I
remember I was going through their
YouTube and I saw the email you see I
love other but I thought I never knew
I'd at the time and she was she's the
producer for a lot the BuzzFeed stuff
and I saw that she put her email that
she put her name at the she signed it at
the bottom of the YouTube so then I
emailed her and I was like you know what
my name is Joyce you know I'm a content
creator I've done this I've done you
know I've got this show on you know
YouTube and this and she was like yeah
you know we've got a show with Victor
kunda that's coming up actually we think
you would you'd be great for it so that
was the first time I met Victor oh yeah
this is why I love Orange's stories yeah
that's my baby but before that's how me
and Victor now started working together
the first time we ever met each other
was on set so I think I was just hang I
was just hungry those times that I knew
I wanted to make it but I knew it also
took work and everything that I did was
a case study for the next thing so the
word on the card thing was that I then
took it to BuzzFeed to be like this is
what I did yeah yeah these are the
numbers I had how can we work together
when I did BuzzFeed it then was
Cadbury's and then when I did cab and
then every time I was just growing and
using the last thing as a portfolio to
what I've done yeah and then I thought
like from like the show and Madame Joyce
worked interchangeably yeah so if Madame
dress
yeah so it didn't matter what who which
guest act on if I did if I had a bigger
guest that week or I did something big
in the personality world yeah they were
both growing like simultaneously
[Laughter]
right guys let's take a very very very
very very very quick break to spread the
word about our friends over at manscape
okay so this summer let's remember it's
not all always about the size of those
cannonballs it's about making a splash
let's go with our friends at manscaped
prep the men in your life for barbecue
season by making sure your special Grill
Master has the hottest dogs The Summer's
ever seen blood clots
when they're at the cookout let the meat
speak for itself with manscapes
performance package 4.0 let's go it's
time to get ready and not sweaty so all
you need to do is head on over to
manscape.com and use this very very very
exclusive special code sng Sierra
November Golf and that's going to give
you 20 off plus free shipping so get on
that now and we will get back to the
episode thank you very much
wow that's very pain thank you for that
yeah that was insightful I actually love
I love stuff like that because like um
it gives you a better understanding of
why the people
have the personalities that they have
and like the things that they say
because like you can say stuff
that is very true to you but if I don't
know where you're coming from I'm just
like okay big man what are you on about
yeah or I can be like cool yeah like
yeah like whatever but once you
understand where someone comes from and
you understand like their experiences
and what they've actually had to do to
get to where there are
because you say I'm not gonna lie you
say audacious statements sometimes and
I'm here for it because I love you and
actually generally think you're very
talented but sometimes I think if anyone
said that I'll say big man big man sharp
but you think you're lucky
because I actually do tell people to
shut up yeah and I've never told you the
shot so um
no I actually believe it but now I
believe it more because like you're uh
yourself because the [__] that
you have done the like being proactive
and all that kind of stuff I promise you
wouldn't do it oh 100 I promise you we
wouldn't do it no yeah made sure you
you're in the right space now because
you've done what you had to do to get it
yeah yeah this whole like stay in your
lane thing you were just praying you
know when people like at the airport and
they're just praying the shorter queue
yeah yeah you were just jumping cues and
then once you made it through security
you're looking back thinking I don't
understand why a man is still in the
same facts facts you should have been
smarter like that yeah but you're
smarter yeah yeah and I think stuff like
that is very pink I think what I think
what is similar to us and what you guys
do amazingly is that you create your own
lane I feel like in this industry
especially in the space we are people
will only support you to a certain point
and if people do not allow you a c you
have to create a table so I feel like
that's kind of what I had to do to
navigate this space
um I I couldn't do it if I was waiting
on somebody or for a for a pick-me-up or
for come and help me my sister my black
sister my brother like I couldn't do
that so it's one of those things where I
say I started saying that lounges things
but it was something that I needed to do
to get people's attention yeah nobody
nobody is coming into this space saying
the things that are safe nobody's coming
to this space saying the things that are
everybody agrees with and you're not
trying to pack a few feathers when I
came in I made sure I'm coming to ruffle
some for others because I want everyone
to turn around and be like who the [__]
is this girl yeah yeah we'd love to see
now before she's never been co-signed by
anyone who is she and I thought like
that was why I had to be so audacious
because I wanted people to be angry
enough to look in my direction I
remember your name and remember the face
yeah exactly yeah
even if it's oh yes that [__] girl
that always opens them up and talks too
much and you should remember at least
you remember me yeah because people be
talking but no one's channel here no one
trying to hear what they have to say no
but I think you do a good job of like
me in the middle like you're not rude to
people yeah and like you don't say stuff
like you're not like a click bait person
yeah like you can say audacious stuff
but it comes from like just a place of
yeah a place of Truth and a place of
comedy and a place of like your
personality yeah as opposed to just
saying stuff that you're like why would
you even say that yeah you don't ever
say [__] that's just like who are you
trying to be yeah like why are you
trying to like you're not bait it's not
for like uh like why are you begging it
yeah or just like why are you
intentionally trying to be antagonistic
or anything like that is very just like
very on brand you're very like yeah
you're tied together okay less or lips
now
[Applause]
[Laughter]
all right cool so before we crack on
we've got some other stuff to do before
um I've got a little thread that I
wanted to read through again yes
um yes so this one based on your
original story this one you will
appreciate 100
so this is a threat I saw yesterday okay
and the title of the thread is what's
one thing a broke woman always got all
right one thing a broke woman always got
attitude this is the first one in there
yeah first one a problem
[Laughter]
let us know if any of these resonate
yeah okay these looting times
second one long ass lashes
25 millimeters okay
now but you're not broke anymore but
that's cool that's not right right this
one's sweetened me one thing a broke
woman always got time today
I've got she's got time today yeah to
beef all for you but time to date no
time to time today bro I've got time
today to be period today okay yeah she's
got time today facts and time to dates
yeah and time today fun that brings me
on to the next one one thing about this
one fam one thing a broke women always
got someone else's man
can you concur I have never you never
had someone else's man you definitely
have someone else's man I actually had
to check myself
go on no I haven't you know no I haven't
not not knowingly
[Laughter]
one thing a bright woman always got a
cracked phone
your phone stays cracked my phone did
say crack you know your phone's stage
did you case it you know what my
insurance is my case
wow you live on the edge
[Applause]
my insurance is my case
what the [__] ever man
that's jokes
bro one thing a broke woman always got
the audacity facts hundreds that's what
you got that's how you got here yes you
had the audacity yeah I me as a black
woman that was a 2K debt yeah would be
telling other men listen you poor don't
speak to me risk is only if you're broke
just say so if you broke just say that
oh raw okay this one isn't you then one
thing a broke woman always got I broke
his back
what's you know what yeah
um
that's actually true I swear guys you
know if you're sharing your Universal
Credit no there was actually a guide
when I was working at the care home I
was dated the care home manager of
course
that's of course why
girl do you know what yeah honestly when
I was younger I was very delused so I
thought like you just heard manager
I just heard manager for the rest of my
time
[Laughter]
Oh my days my ninja
anyways so wait did you coerce this
relationship or do you actually
attracted his brother no do you know
what honestly I actually thought he had
money like I had manager
no I liked him but he also because he
was manager for oh yeah you know guys
I'm dating the boss
okay anyways
right one thing a broke woman always got
fresh nails
do you know what yeah I [__] hate
this yes I hate this a lot because
honestly this is how I carried my nails
to the Barbie Premiere and it they're
just so awful just don't look around
just because you're that's because no my
nails is actually saying do you know
what because the time it takes I loved
getting my nails done but my schedule
the time it takes to see your nails you
have to at least have two hours out of a
day to do it to be sitting down and yeah
and not doing anything well your books
are busy now isn't it so it's crazy yeah
but that's why my nails look like this
is what it is
what it is you got the louvi bag to
distract yes I still put my fingers in
your mouth huh
who said that it's a family sure
all right cool right a couple more one
thing a broke woman always got the tea
what's the problem
nothing I ain't got a problem
okay guys don't be fooled by the rocks
that I got yeah I'm still I'm still
dressy From the Block used to have a
little boy and got a lot no matter where
I go I know where I came from and I
always have the tea all right gang
period fair play you don't know that
song
wrong
women
are enablers yeah facts
he's like girl shut up
the women are women are enablers they'll
clap for anything anything another woman
does they'll clap what that's where my
ego comes from is that yeah
literally no anything a woman says a
conviction yeah if you say it with chess
yeah everyone's clicking and clapping he
doesn't buy you sausage roll yeah he's
not your man who was that chick that was
on Twitter
um
talking about broke guys she was like he
was she was saying something along the
lines of um if he can't do it she can
she can do you remember she was like a
tracksuit
wait no is it the low vibrational meal
lady yeah
that food is low vibrational I think I
think I was playing over there is a low
vibration she was going on a rant for
like a week or so people were supporting
her a week Charlie in her background in
her videos of course of course of course
of course
it was mad
you don't know about sprinkle sprinkle
not sprinkle sprinkle you don't know
about sprinkles what's up girls if you
if you if you know about sprinkle
sprinkle comment below
a broke woman always got expensive taste
buds how fast
me yeah I remember let me tell you like
when I was 17 yeah working a River
Island for four pounds 73. jeez I went
on a date and let me tell you where I
went for my first ever date I went to a
place in Vauxhall yeah I can't remember
what the place was oh yeah Chino Latino
is in here
Latino that's a one of one yeah guys I
could have honestly had five pounds
every three in my account that got stuck
with sashida Latino and it's the first
time I ever had tempura Lobster
because I said it's the most expensive
thing on the menu that Lobster was 100
113 pounds swear and I bought and I said
get me that Lobster and I've got the
lobster and I ate it and I took my five
pounds of e3 back to Bedford
fair play yes and I'm gonna do it again
fair play fair enough all right so
unless I can't say nothing expensive
taste buds [__] one thing a broke woman
always got her two cents true fair true
excited to say about myself
one last one one thing a broke woman
always got good [__]
brother
I'm not gonna lie
oh you broke you're not broke you're
original no [__] oh yeah sorry I mean
sorry I'm representing all that I'm
representing all the broke bad beings
yard she opens the door and it's still
in pajamas and it's 3 P.M yeah you know
the clap's gonna be mad no Brooke does
that wear pajamas we wear our X's boxers
that's actually fact the Nike ones well
extra stretches halfway down the thigh
yeah excuse me
oh yeah yeah
yeah
it just tucks down the fupa
let's go it comes High Enough
[Laughter]
[Music]
we're going to move on to the question
part of the um show so the call babies
have asked some questions they that you
would like to answer okay um but I will
pass you the iPad and then you can
answer the question read the questions
out one by one and then answer them
yourself yeah hello cult babies my name
is Madame Joyce and I am going to be
reading some of your very special
questions and I'm really excited
it's moving like a CBeebies she is right
I always see people attacking you for
being your authentic self how do you
deal with that well first of all I like
to imagine my haters in a basement oh my
God Alone
poor on concrete
pour on concrete yeah no carpet No
honestly in my mind my haters are on the
mattress
iPhone 4 but please upgrade
um and I feel like sometimes you just
have to accept when you're on the public
eye people reflect their insecurities
Onto You true and
um I feel like me being my authentic
self allows the bad boys and girls which
are my supporters to be their authentic
selves because I feel like in a world
full of people who are fake and scared
to be a hundred percent themselves and
living their truth I feel like it's
important for me to show my truth so
that other people can show their truth
so one is the bad boys and girls and two
because my haters live on piss day
mattresses in my mind
okay so
would she be open to do it early fans
for the right amount of money swear it's
a juicy question okay good clap on only
fans to be fair you know what yeah I
would love to be if I was to do only
fancy I'd love to be a dominatrix
like I feel like first of all I proper
love leather that's the first thing like
I'm surprised as I have my leather
trousers on that food had loved so much
just say stuff
Jesus Christ but yeah and being
Dominator I mean I've had one instance
while I was a double nature so somebody
wanted me to step on him and stuff
you've been a dominatrix did you say
I've had a dominatrous experience oh
talk us through that so basically I was
seeing a guy yeah and they wanted me to
step on him everywhere like literally he
was on the floor and I was stepping on
him and then he he told me that he
wanted me to to tell him to bark like a
dog and and be like all fours around his
house and stuff
that was actually quite fun and I also
had very early on on my show somebody
asked me to send them voice notes of
saying that their mom is a [__] and
stuff I needed to pay for the studio
time so I did it
question so with this domination stuff
that you did with this person this was
it just the one time
it was just the one time so in this one
time did you find it you said you found
it interesting but did it turn you on or
did you guys
listen yeah I've heard bear times
um that like people who work as a
dominatrist like it doesn't turn them on
in the slightest okay they just find the
same flattering and fun okay I just
thought I can't believe I [__] doing
this for I kind of found I found it more
funny and I can't believe I'm doing this
this is the guy you were seeing
yes and you banged him afterwards no we
never banged you know
oh interesting very interesting he did
clean my house there and stuff oh I did
[__] yeah this is not manager better is
it huh this is not manager brother is it
they're from the care home no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no that one day but yeah I
would I think if I was the only fans I'd
be a mistress is that what they call it
they call it
there you go you can literally I would
be bad
give me bags Joyce who knows maybe
that's my rebrands who knows yeah don't
be dming me don't be naughty
[__] sake
next question how do I get to be on your
show I have a lot to rant about please
invite me first of all big up
[__] you I always love people
who want to come on the show I always
say it's so important for me have some
content people always want to come on
the show because they feel like they're
great chat but it's very different to
have a conversation in the kitchen with
your friends
in the living room than to be on the
show that has you know x amount of
thousand people per week so
please make sure that you have some
content to show me even if you're not
like a YouTuber just have some talking
something do something first so I can
see you so yeah I'm big up you hopefully
I'll see you soon that was very
wholesome and cute by the way third and
I are very dismissive
next he'll delete the whole thing no
because it's always nice I always love
when some people comment to me like
Joyce it's my dream to come on the show
and stuff banging and I love and I
really love that like that's amazing but
please have some content don't just be
like can I come audition your videos
like nah but I'm lit in real life it's
just that girl yeah
sorry Alice was swearing
question is
it is Sugar Baby MJ you know what I say
in this I feel like when I hit a stand
age I will be a sugar mommy
um you're gonna pan a little young thing
I swear to God so what age range I'll be
talking let's say let's say now you're
40. what age range would you dabble in
25 26. it depends in his lifestyle
honestly I swear to God I will I feel
like if I'm in when I get to my 40s 50s
60s if the marriage the second marriage
doesn't work out she already knows if
the sakaria doesn't work out you're
charging the whole game I'm gonna be a
sugar Mommy I have it in me because I
love to spoil people I love to spend
money like I feel like I would really
look after my sugar baby boy like
seriously yeah I feel like I'm bad I
believe it I believe I would I would I
would say you know what yeah I'm So
Young I'm bouncy to be a sugar mommy but
just oxy again in 15 years we'll see
where I am saying it's in the cause for
me to be a sugar mommy 100 okay
I was about to say something but I'm
just not gonna say it all right cool
yeah how do you wipe your butt with
those nails with your tongue
I Fair we're clapping back immediately
immediately that was reflexive that was
she's had that question yeah
with your tongue and you liked it all
right
he said this is a family show dress it's
actually not but I'm just yeah this is a
family Choice what's your biggest
insecurity oh vulnerable moment
what's my biggest insecurity I would say
I'm generally a very confident person
sometimes being in this space where you
are surrounded by itsy bitsy skinny
girls sometimes I'm like oh you know
what yeah maybe I just need to just lose
a couple of pounds or maybe I just need
to have a smaller waist or sometimes you
do get into that space where you compare
yourself to like the other people in the
room but then I just remember I said you
know what yeah to be fair yeah like they
might be skinny but my ass is fat so
like sometimes it's give and take that
you're not gonna have everything and I
feel like I I love myself and I
represent so many other women that look
like me and there's not much
representations of the thicker girls of
the bigger girls in this space so I
don't mind being that but I guess
sometimes when I'm seeing you know small
waists small waist cutie I could be like
okay maybe I can you know the six-pack
would be bad for me but
[Applause]
okay what's the one thing you do in a
marriage That Others May find
unconventional
I feel like after a certain amount of
time in a marriage I would be okay with
having boyfriends and girlfriends yeah
that's a juicy take I'm here elaborate
I'm here for it yeah I'm here for it
elaborate I feel like obviously being
married for 50 60 years like obviously
like marriage essentially is supposed to
be for Life yeah you're gonna be with
that one Pastor for the rest of your
life and from what I heard about
marriage it gets to a point where it
starts to feel like brother and sister
yeah yeah yeah I feel like in the later
stages of marriage when you've been
together for 30 40 years and as an
individual woman you're looking for a
new excitement I would have a little
boyfriend on the side would you be it
and would this be discussed yeah okay
your significance
yeah I thought that we can both have
things like I said I'm I'm in the cost
to be a Sugar by me so if that's in or
out of marriage then so be I swear
that's an interesting thing very
interesting I feel like it's I feel like
I've I'm Coming to Terms of with like
Society now and the way like
marriage is looking you know there are
so many factors that have changed like
the how conventional marriage is
compared to like being married in the
50s or the 60s I think I'm just kind of
being adaptable to the times just how
like people go into marriages but they
still like have threesomes and stuff
like that like I think join later in my
marriage I would want to be spicy and I
wouldn't want to be want someone to make
me feel sexy in my 50s or 60s I would
get myself a little six-pack 20 year old
so see Daddy yeah you know what I mean
making me feel young again and [__]
gang yeah
These Are Juicy questions by the way
good curation
this is the gang thank you guys thank
you how have you felt before and after
your live show
so before my show I was waking up every
day of anxiety my biggest fear is Public
Disgrace it's
it's one thing embarrassing but black
disgrace that's such a hilarious ball
yeah totally flat on your face he's
actually in front of people it's my
biggest fear yeah I woke up because I'm
like what if people don't come what if
you know it doesn't go to plan people
think it's [__] like I had so many fears
before the show yeah that I was I was
mentally and emotionally dealing with
yeah after the show
I was on top of the world I kept
thinking about burning sitting on top of
the world top of the world that was my
answer
I was on top of the world I think it's
one thing having a show on the internet
yeah I feel like sometimes we don't copy
to mentalize
yes that's the word yeah
to mentalize the amount of people and
people and supporters that actually love
us because we see the numbers and it's
like oh 100K oh that's nice 1.4 million
views on Tick Tock okay q and we don't
think that those are actual people human
beings in it human beings I try to do
that sometimes it gets to a point where
it's like it's physically impossible
physically impossible you know what 1.4
million people looks like you know
together there's not a festival in the
world like that that can do that exactly
to then see people in a room I don't
know if you you guys didn't see me as I
came out but when I came out I screamed
I screamed because I could not believe
the people in the room and that was only
1 500 people I was like this is crazy
that these people came on a Tuesday in
the shoes they got babysitters and also
coming out for me some people some
people came from Australia
I love that U.S to come to the show and
I think when you start to see your
supporters live oh yeah you appreciate
the people more because I sometimes we
calling James on that James everybody
hates me that's the reality yeah I'm
like yeah they all hate me yeah but I
think seeing the love in that room for
me
um was incredible and it really I'm
still on a high but I think I'm just
coming down now and I'm like okay what's
next but the the last three days
honestly nobody could chat to me I was
so happy I kept re reliving and
re-watching the moments over and over
again yeah good but that's the last one
Mike I have a question for you it was
going to be you just said it um what's
next from Adam Joyce what's next for
Madame Joyce
oh wow I'm gonna be your neighbor soon
because I'm moving my studio is gonna be
here so I'm gonna be looking at you as I
actually had now well we're not going to
be recording the same day so you won't
I'll make sure I record next to you but
yeah I'm moving into into citizen gigs
Haiti cult HQ would you call this place
HQ I'm moving into HQ next door so
that's that's amazing I can't wait to
have a set that's mine and again the
creative process of building something
is something I always love I think
that's why I started my show in the
first place
um also
um
production wise um I've got something
coming up I'd love to do more I think
after this show I really enjoyed putting
my director hat on because it was self
it was self-produced self-directed so I
think I definitely want to do more of
those projects okay and yeah just having
a good time and enjoying every moment
really I feel like for me as long as you
have God and as long as you have
confidence in yourself just just enjoy
now enjoying the ride I feel like when I
first started it was graft fight for
your life for your life for your life
now I'm at a very comfortable place I'm
just actually taking in and registering
that life is beautiful and yes it has
its ups and downs yes sometimes people
call me fat [__] on the internet but I
have a great time doing what I do and
waking up loving what I enjoy doing so
that's what it is
we've got a game for you you may have
been familiar with it from our show it's
called finish the lyrics yes so
um you get a point for
finishing obviously finishing lyrics you
get an extra point for the artist you
get a third point for the name of the
song as well
does that make sense okay so what do I
win if I win well you just you get a
score you get a score and at the end of
the year yeah if you win overall you win
overall then we'll plan your time what's
this outfit we'll talk
yeah are you gonna pay for my breast
your what your breasts yeah how much is
that 7K seven yeah no I mean that's if
you win you might not yeah you probably
won't win you probably won't win that
probably what's your what's your I know
because I know you love uh afrobeats I
do I'm a little I'm a PP yeah yeah but
we we didn't we didn't give you the easy
stuff we just curious so what's your
what's your general music knowledge like
I'm pretty good all right fair play okay
all right so I've got we've got seven in
total right we've got seven songs right
you go first so what's the highest score
right now uh we've only had days I've
only had taser do it and what did he get
I can't remember 19. 19 there we go it's
a long time ago 19 points yeah so the
maximum points is what 21 points uh
three whatever three times seven is 21
points okay he's sure he got 19 out of
21. he I think he got 18 or 17 18 or 19.
we saw I thought he was [__] as well I
thought he got like 15 to be honest or
something like that we might have to be
up we might have been generous you know
because he was asked we can revisit but
I just watched the video all right we'll
we'll we'll we'll we'll curate the
episode to make sure that he got the
correct points he should deserve but
we're not gonna go easy on you yeah
you're going first yeah I'll go first
all right so like I said you get 1.4
continuing the lyrics you get one point
for the artist and you get a third and
final point for the name of the song
okay you ready yes for sure yeah 100
years will fit in an SUV sis somebody
rescued me I got too many about too many
sexual c
um Dave sprinterest gang what I'm gonna
say in a British British voice so that
you don't get too many Clues
right are you ready you know I play this
game all the time on my show so all
right gang that's calm good as well why
are you clapping back I'm ready to
listen I'm gonna pay for my babies
listen
right
only been a few hours but it feels like
days
yeah
yeah do I need to do all of it been gone
for a year only wrote like once and then
I want you to say
that's not [__] bad yes it is you
said the next line I said the next line
cut me off I wasn't finished I was gonna
say the whole three lines sorry I was
gonna give you the next line you got
eager and then decided to say my bit
okay sorry cool I only been announced
for like days only been days where for
like months been gone for a year and
write like once this is the most famous
bit so if you don't know this bit it's
your business
[Laughter]
the only one
one point for Joyce please guys no two I
got the lyrics right you did not get the
lyrics right that's a song called
only one
Jackie Brown
no it's called he literally I literally
just said Jackie Brown and you said only
one
I just guessed the lyrics all right gang
next up flakes all right okay you ready
yes uh come here waiting they worry you
come here today where are you
Grace
um Grandma charms Let's Go Gang fair
play fair play fair play another three
points
right this is easy I'm gonna say two
words and you yeah if you can't pattern
that's your business I was about to
start thinking to you all right you
ready shut up let me concentrate sorry
apps you're 22.
this is easy you're 22 you're 22.
too hot to handle
why I wanna handle yeah right
Song and j-o 22. all right guys
thank you you said this before so I'm
really Jarred but I had this on here
anyway all right
I'm just trying to be me
I'm just trying to be me yeah all right
I'll sing it in the actual thingy I'm
just trying to be me
oh maybe not I'm lost myself I'm just
trying to be me doing what I gotta do
some people think that out sitting on
top of the world it's like it is but I
can't give you that it's mad because
it's the burner boy version wait let me
finish no no you were singing them you
know you were singing it is it brand new
or Monica you know you were singing that
version hold on I know you were singing
that version nah to be fair in her
defense earlier today she said the
burner boy version hold on that's the
reason why I thought you'd guess no guys
that's how you know there's the other
issue here all right if if somebody
sampled a song and I sang the original
version I'm rejoice in this one should I
still get the point for the original
version of Jason this one it's not her
fault
if you sang Verbatim lyrics from the
original it's not her fault if she
continues the song of the original thank
you you sung the original song from the
original yeah
it's not in the car actually it
don't remember which one it's Brandy
I think what's the name of the song of
the title it's sitting on top of the
world by Brandy that is the original
version
I'm gonna I'm gonna override for eggs on
this one and give it I don't think it's
fair I don't think it's fair fair enough
okay Daddy is fair oh no Okay cool so I
thought you were no ignore me ignore me
ignore me right
oops
right last one is the last one right you
got one more okay
last time I saw you we ain't speak that
was strange
guess there's nothing I can do mine is
true
right let me say it the last time I saw
you last time I saw you when I speak
that was strange guess there's nothing I
can do man it's true
X has changed for the better all right
what's it called song artist Drake No
wow
this would happen what I think about you
oh all right
that was in myself you bastard Drake
with chess
[Laughter]
all right last but not least
this should be is I'm livid all right
are you do you want 10 seconds to change
it no no no I'm keeping it safe are you
sure I'm sure okay all right give me
best soul mwah
give me best though extendo I carry
[__] like I probably go
all right say less
oh no it's not glorious
wait wait what's this small guy Lola
's Lola Rose
Lola Ah that's gonna bug me
give me best salt
expect though I'll carry a [__] stuck
up I go
don't play don't play with it Lola Rose
I'm sure it's Lola Rose two points is
Lola brook let's go
the calculations was wrong it was 19 in
total 19 in total and she got 18. out of
21. let me we must have dashed some
points yeah we're gonna we're gonna
we're gonna exam we're gonna examine
it's like you you smashed it yeah yeah
but we'll see that was thank you that
was banging but anyway uh Joyce thank
you very much for uh joining us today it
was a long episode it was a good one it
was it was a good one I was gonna say
before we like sign off and everything
just let everyone know where they can
catch you where they can find you what's
your out what's your social all of them
your subscribership
you know what yeah guys can I just say
cult babies yeah why are you reaching
tall people [__] some Geeks have been
laughing at because I haven't hit 100K
yet
yes
okay so I'd love to hit 100K so if you
go to cocktails or takeaways which is
under Madame Joyce on YouTube you will
find our show there so after this one
go-karts has the takeaways and have some
fun there and listen to the podcast and
Instagram I am Madame Joyce with an e on
Tick Tock I am Madame Joyce with an e or
maybe you'll find me on early fans in
dominatrix hey come on all right gang
guys thank you very much
[Music]
thank you